hallo ich meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zu einer neuen folge
der minecraft facts
letzte woche kam keine folge weil ich
die ganze woche unterwegs war ich war
wirklich die ganze woche lang ihr habt
ihr gesehen er ich habe ein video
gemacht wo ich eine woche in meinem
leben gezeigt habe ich war in london
ich war auch noch in stuttgart und in wo
ich dann noch in köln war ich noch und
am nürburgring und alles mögliche
also tut mir leid das letzte woche kein
effekt kam dafür kommen diese woche
welche obwohl ich gerade wenn ihr das
seht auch wieder in bulgarien bin ich
fahr letzter zeit so ein bisschen proben
na ja ich wollte erstmal das ganz
übliche wenn irgendwelche fact schon mal
irgendwo vorgekommen sind
meckert nicht mich an seiner meckert die
leute an die ich erwähne weil die
schickt mir die fake zu hand konkreter
gmail.com welt steht auch nochmal unten
in der beschreibung da könnt ihr mit
effekten nur cool effect nicht so was
wie wenn man mit linksklick auf dem blog
steht er kaputt das kriege ich immer
noch zugesendet so ein schwachsinn
coole bikes bitte dahin schreiben und
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
dem ersten vers zugesendet von simon
hallo ingo chu er meint und zwar das
ganze neuesten snapshot deswegen habe
ich auch kein shader am start
im neuesten snapshot wurden jetzt
endlich die schwämme aktiviert will
finden sie hier ein sponge in einem spot
wir sehen hier unten schon da es im
redstone dass ein normaler sponge
machten beide kaputt und zwar wenn ich
ja in rage versetzte passiert nix
allerdings wenn ich einen sponge
einsetze dann sagt er direkt das ganze
wasser auf weil jetzt hier mit meiner
mittlere maustaste darauf clique krieger
wieder die blog hier und das ist ein
brett sponge also fakt daran ist einfach
dass dieses ponchos hinzugefügt wurden
ich will nicht diese snapshot vorstellen
und über diese ganzen snap dass wenn
viel zu viel videos sondern einfach nur
der effekt ist dass jetzt dieses dass
dieses porsches diese schwelle wurden
jetzt endlich wieder aktiviert die wand
ist ganz damals in irgendeiner kleinen
beta alpha version gab es diemal dann
wollen sie wieder rausgenommen
jetzt gibt sie wieder und ich finde
eigentlich ganz cool ich weiß noch nicht
genau wie man die kraft hat aber sie
wollen auf jeden fall hinzugefügt wenn
ich hier in sponge einsätze sagt er das
ganze wasser auf
hier ein bisschen uncool war okay das
ist wirklich ein bisschen uncool aber
das war auf jeden fall fällig nummer 1
jo und damit sind wir auch schon beim
geheimnisvollen geräusch angelangt und
zwar wo das letzte geheimnisvolle
geräusche erraten von minecraft freaky
gegen aurich ordners die zündung von
einem creeper direkt vorm explodieren
ist und das heutige geräusch was sie
heute erraten müsst oder könnt und mehr
als einfache direkt in die kommentare
schreiben könnte ist das hier
ich denke werde ich mal ein bisschen
schwieriger ich hoffe mal dass ihr das
hinkriegt aber ich denke geschafft hast
du dieses mal viel spaß weiterhin bei
den fans weckt nummer zwei wurde mir
zugesendet von justin und zwar erkennt
dass moment ich nehme mal ganz kurz hier
in die am man schwer aus
ihr kennt das wenn ich einen mob töte
sagen wie beispielsweise ein schwein
kommt da erfahrungen aus ich kann das
ganze auch im game 1 0 machen das seht
ihr mal ganz kurz daran jetzt wenn ich
beispielsweise goethe jetzt aber gab
doch schon bei dem schwein gehört also
ich bin jetzt bei 66 zeigt darauf mit
meinem finger ich vollidiot so und jetzt
ist meine fahne hoch gegangen
wenn ich allerdings moment ich dir mal
ganz kurz raus und jetzt habe ich
außerdem weggedrückt ich vollidiot jetzt
gehe ich mal hier ganz kurz raus und
hier zum village ag ich mal ganz kurz
rein und zwar sind villiger die einzigen
mops die keine erfahrung drop also ihr
seht schon die schlag den bla bla bla
bla noch zu ihm hin und ich habe keine
erfahrung dazu bekommen ihr habt nichts
gehört und nichts gesehen
das liegt ganz einfach daran dass diese
will ja also ich habe mir das erst zu
erklären wollen dass diese will ja
eigentlich total liegt zu 1 sind und
einem nichts tun und wenn man die tötet
sollte man keine erfahrung bekommen
sondern lieber erfahrungen abgezogen
bekommen aber die sache ist halt was tun
einem kühl und was tut ein schweine onyx
mörder sollte man ja auch keine
erfahrungen kommen also ich weiß nicht
warum vielleicht liegt es auch nur an
meinem skin dass ich dann keine
erfahrung bekommen weil ich meine
mitmenschen getötet habe oder irgendwie
so aber fakt ist auf jeden fall dass
keine erfahrung mit der dritte weg wurde
mir zugesendet von dieter und zwar mein
dieter dass man im hardcore-modus
schiiten kann dadurch dass man sie im
laden öffnet und dann kann man ja diese
chips aktivieren
also ist er hart komme gar kein
richtiger hardcore modus wenn ihr
beispielsweise realisiert okay kommt
eine hardcore modus welt ist ganz geil
wenn ich sterbe wäre blöd wenn die weg
wer soll deswegen ich mal ganz kurzen
hardcore neue welt erstellen welt wird
geladen bla bla bla bla
dann lädt das ganz kurz und wenn ihr
euch beispielsweise denkt ok kommen ich
hab eine welt im hardcore-modus
angefangen aber die ist richtig geil ich
lebe auch schon richtig lange aber das
wird hart korrekt nicht aufhalten
england sterbe sollt zu arg jetzt hier
gerade noch ein bisschen weh sich das
hier alles aufbaut soll eine
wunderschöne welt
ich kann gar nicht weit gucken ob es im
sap geht ja gar nicht richtig
eingestellt da egal deswegen ist auch
einfach alles hier so einfach so flüssig
cool ich bin jetzt wenn ich sterbe ich
tot aber ich kann hier moment ihres im
laden öffnen machen und da kann ich die
chips erlauben und da kann ich den
spielmodus auch auf irgendwie kreativ
stellen und dann können quasi andere
leute dazukommen oder ich selbst auch
und dann ist die ganze welt gar nicht
mehr so hart kommt sondern dann ist das
ganze im kreativ modus auch er spielbar
und das ist eigentlich cool aber
andererseits auch ein bisschen doof weil
ich find's ganz cool wenn man quasi
hierbei laden öffnen dann einfach
auswählen könnte da konnt man gar nichts
sondern wer die welt einfach offen und
jeder andere wäre auch ein hardcore
spieler also es hat ja keinen richtigen
sinn aber dank auf jeden fall ein
dichter dafür dass du mir das gesendet
hat der nächste feld wurde mit
zugesendet von 4x hd und zwar ihr seht
schon jetzt eine kiste mit 16
schneebällen drin und wenn ich mit einem
schneeball gegen einen rahmen werfen
springt dieses item einfach raus ich
kann auch jetzt eine ganze kiste neben
die karriere einstellen kann man jetzt
ja um 19 40 uhr noch drehen kann die
mögliche grund gedreht haben so kann
manchmal auch moment ich mir noch im
radio soll so ein schneeball gegen und
es verschwindet einfach das feld einfach
raus ist ist weg ich kann auch einen
rahmen nehmen und den rahmen in den
rahmen reinsetzen kann mir die schneebar
dagegen werfen und das ist weg und
irgendwann ist dann auch noch der rahmen
weg und alles mögliche der block geht
natürlich nicht weg das war natürlich
noch der absolute wahnsinn hier
aber der rahmen geht irgendwann weg und
das auf was da drin ist zeigt seine mal
ganz kurz so dass da drin weg so und
jetzt der rahmen weg das auf den verkauf
mit schnee bank aber das zerstören also
anstatt einfach gegen boxt wenn ihr eure
das haus von einem komplett kaputt
machen wollt einfach mit schneebällen
überall rum werfen und dann würde ich
sagen was das auch schon mit den
heutigen minecraft er ist ging mal
wieder ein bisschen schneller ich wollte
das ganze auch nicht mehr so lange
halten wenn die cool effect ist und wenn
ihr denkt dass diese waren dann schreibt
mir einfach per mail an kontrast
gmail.com da lese ich mir jede mail
durch und wenn er was coole bei ist
das ist mittlerweile auch sein gegner
das ist in jeder folge einfach anfängt
zu regnen
das regt mich mittlerweile schon da bin
ich auch mit shader sah das immer noch
cool aus aber so einen snapshot ist
alles ein bisschen anders aber ich
find's cool dass hier so flüssig läuft
in diesem snapshot läuft bei dem ja egal
wenn es euch gefallen hat lasst uns
bitte mit nehme ich mich mit einer
bewertung wissen das geheimnisvolle
geräusche habt ihr in dieser folge
wieder irgendwann gesehen könnten in die
kommentare schreiben
da will ich sagen sehen wir uns morgen
wieder bei einem neuen video teams